الان الى تطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا
حيث ذكرت وكاله انترفيكس الروسيه للانباء
ان خليج سيفاستوبل قد اغلق امام حركه
المرور بعد هجوم بطائره مسيره على المدينه
اليوم من جهته اعلى نحاكم
وسيباسيفي شبه جزيره القرم ان اسطول البحر
الاسود صدى هجوما لطائره مسيره لم يسفر عن
اضرار او اصابات ياتي ذلك بعد ان كشفت
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه ان الدفاعات الجويه
اسقطت ثلاث مسيرات اوكرانيه كانت في
طريقها لاستهداف خليج سيفا ستوبل وكانت
سلطات شبه الجزيره قد اعلنت تفعيل انظمه
الدفاع الجوي مساء الاثنين في مدينه
جانكوي بعد اصابه شخص اثر سقوط حطام طائره
مسيره على احد منازلها
من جهتها قالت الاداره العسكريه في كييف
فان الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه اسقطت ثمن
طائره مسيره من طراز شاهد كانت متجهه نحو
العاصمه كما قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان وحدات من دفاعاتها صدت 114 هجوما
للقوات الروسيه على الجزء الشرقي من
الجبهه واضاف البيان ان القوه الروسيه
نفذت اثنتين ضربه جويه وبلغ عدد هجماتها
الصاروخيه 90 هجوما بينما نفذ طيران
الاوكراني 6 ضربات على مناطق تتمركز فيها
القوات الروسيه
واسقطت 15 مسيره روسيه من مختلف الانواع
اضافه الى صاروخين موجهين من طراز كي اتش
المتابعه تنضم الينا من دوناتك مراسله
الجزيره رانيا دريدي ومن كيف مراسل
الجزيره حسن مسعود ارحب بكم ما ابدا معك
حسان اي بيانات عسكريه اوكرانيه جديده
قد تكون رصدت التطورات في القرن وايضا في
الشرق الاوكراني
نعم ازدهار اخر البيانات ايضا تحدثت هنا
عن العاصمه كييف ومحيطها حيث اعلنت قبل
قليل الاداره الاقليميه لمنطقه كييف ان
ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا وسبعه اصيبوا في قصف
بمسيارات انتحاريه استهدفت منطقه هذا
اليوم هذا الاعلان اتى بعدما كانت قياده
الاداره العسكريه في منطقه كييف قد اعلنت
عن اسقاطها لثماني مسيرات انتحاريه من
طراز شاهد ايضا استهدفت منطقه كيافا خلال
الليله الفائته هذا ياتي في اطار ضربات
صاروخيه ايضا تعرضت لها منطقه اوديسا وادت
الى اصابه اربعه اشخاص وتدمير منشاه قالت
الاداره العسكريه هناك انها مدنيه ياتي
ذلك ايضا بينما اعلنت قياده القوات الجويه
عن اسقاطها ليسارخين من ط 59 اطلقت من
البحر الاسود باتجاه منطقه اوديسا
بالاضافه الى 16 مسيره انتحاريه من اصل 21
مسيره اطلقت باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه من
شمال
البلاد تحديدا من منطقه
الروسيه هذا فيما يتعلق بالضربات الجويه
التي كانت فجر اليوم طيله الليل كانت تدوي
صفارات الانذار وحتى قبل قليل ايضا تدوي
صفارات الانذار ويتم الانذار الجوي في
عموم الاراضي الاوكرانيه اما في الشرق
هيئه الاركان العليا تحدثت عن صدها لاكثر
من 114 هجوما في المناطق الشرقيه هذه
الهجمات ابرزها كانت في منطقه باخموت
بالاضافه الى المنطقه التي تشهد هجمات
مشابهه لما يحدث في بخموت منطقه افديسكا
في المنطقه الجنوبيه للمناطق التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه وكذلك
في منطقتي الليما وشختار شرق البلاد
بالاضافه الى منطقه كوبيانسك الشارقه
مقاطعه هذه التطورات الميدانيه اما فيما
يتعلق بالقرب فحتى هذه اللحظه لم يصدر اي
بيانات او تعليق عن الضربه الجديده انما
كان هناك حديث عن المسيرات التي استهدفت
شبه جزيره القرن قبل
النقطه هذه تاتي في اطار هجمات على
المنشات الاستراتيجيه
وايضا طرق الامداد نعم كما ذكرت في هذه
النقطه انتقل الى رانيا الروايه الروسيه
المتعلقه باسقاط طائرات في القرن وايضا
التطورات في جبهه ضخمه رانيا
نعم ازدهار فيما يتعلق بتطورات الاوضاع في
شبه جزيره القرم نعم تم التاكيد انه لليوم
الثاني على التوالي تعرضت شبه جزيره القرم
لهجوم بالمسيرات هذه المره الهجوم جاء من
نصيب مدينه سيره ستوبل وكان حاكم المدينه
قد اكد ان الحادث وقع صباح اليوم وهذه
المره تم استخدام
لتنفيذه ثلاث مسيرات بحريه
على خلاف المسيرات الجويه التي تم
استخدامها امس في شمال شبه جزيره القرم
حسب التصريحات الرسميه
قوات الاسطول البحر الاسود الروسي البحاره
قاموا باستخدام الاسلحه الخفيفه لاسقاط
احدى هذه المسيرات بينما مسيرتين اخرىين
تم اسقاطهما باستخدام انظمه الدفاع الجوي
العامله في مدينه سيوستوبل على خلفيه هذه
الاحداث تم الاعلان اليوم من قبل هيئه
النقل والمواصلات في مدينه سباستوبال
تعليق حركه المرور البحري المدني دون
الافصاح باي التفاصيل تتعلق في هذا الشان
ولكن غالبا ما تقوم السلطات شبه جزيره
القرم باتخاذ مثل هذه الخطوات اما بسبب
سوء الاحوال الجويه ام بسبب اي هجمات
تتعرض لها المنطقه بما في ذلك باستخدام
المسيرات هذا الحادث ياتي بعد مرور يوم
واحد فقط على هجوم اخر كانت القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه نفذته بحسب تصريحات
الجانب الروسي امس على مدينه جانكوي
الواقعه في شمال شبه جزيره القرم كانت
هناك محاولات لاستهداف محطه القطارات في
هذه المدينه ولكن هذه المحاولات بحسب
السلطات الروسيه كانت قد باءت بالفشل تم
اسقاط هذه المسيرات ولكن حطام احدى هذه
المسيرات وقع على احدى المباني السكنيه
واحد المتاجر في المنطقه ما تسبب بي اصابه
احد المدنيين بجروح هذا فيما يتعلق بشبه
جزيره القرم لكن من مراسله الجزيره رانيا
دريدي والشكر موصول لمراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود